[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily r
kelly's trial is back in session with
striking testimony from more accusers
why some are speaking out for the first
time saying the singer used his studio
as a place to sexually assault them
susan posed a threat to him the
prosecution rams up in the closing
arguments in robert durst trial we'll
take you through jury instructions and
hear from state prosecutors who detailed
durst's alleged history with lying more
delays in the case of the doomsday duo
how the trials of lori valodebel and
chad daybel have been pushed off even
further but first day two of the
landmark trial against elizabeth holmes
continues i think she believes that she
is the best possible advocate for
herself and her business and hear her
case law and crimes top analysts break
down opening statements and explain what
we could see in what's expected to be a
lengthy trial law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin thursday marks day two for the
highly anticipated trial of elizabeth
holmes former theron ceo
opening statements began on wednesday as
the prosecution painted holmes as a
manipulative fraud and a cheap while the
defense framed her as a hard-working
startup executive who faced
unprecedented challenges
back in 2003 a 19 year old homes founded
the now defunct theranos a company she
says was aimed at revolutionizing blood
testing during its run she convinced
investors to donate 700 million dollars
to the company later investigators
revealed that technology had serious
issues the stanford university dropout
is now charged with 10 counts of wire
fraud and two counts of conspiracy to
commit wire fraud if convicted
37-year-old holmes could face up to two
decades in prison in documents filed
ahead of the trial holmes has put the
blame on ramish sonny bowani her
ex-boyfriend and former theranos
executive holmes of the fans argued
belwani manipulated and abused her it
was expected to be a 13-week trial legal
experts say holmes defense will have to
pay close attention to this jury
how does her body language and tone of
voice change we know that she had a very
distinctive and some say put on or fake
tone of voice
with her investors
if she testifies and i believe she will
how does she sound all of these things
going to be very interesting in order to
win here she has to see things from her
jury's perspective and then tell a story
that resonates with that perspective
it's a little bit harder when they vary
so so
so widely
joining us today is legal analyst dina
dahl and terry austin dean with the
defense not mentioning the abuse and
their opening statements only that
bowani had a temper was that surprising
to you considering holmes's motions to
the court
it was a little bit surprising because
they they said in the filing that they
were going to allude to this but it was
smart because if you say something in
opening statement you have better
back it up with proof so that doesn't
necessarily mean they won't end up
introducing evidence to the abuse but it
gives them the leeway because most
likely she would have to take the stand
if they do want to approve some sort of
abuse happen and she probably doesn't
know yet if she wants to take the stand
so instead they kind of led with the
fact that she was being overly
influenced by him he was much older and
that this she's making mistakes and not
malice so they kind of alluded to the
fact that he
you know had something to do with it
without going as far as alleging the
abuse yeah that might be a game time
decision depending on how the testimony
comes in and that's in large part is to
the witnesses terry the prosecution's
witness list has some huge names like
ex-theron's board members former
secretary of state henry kissinger and
former defense secretary james mattis
should we expect them to be testifying
i do think there's a good chance that we
are going to see some of those witnesses
there are 180 names on the government's
list including kissinger and mattis and
there's some other big names like
murdoch the amigo media mogul and also
david boyce who's this prominent
attorney so we might see some of them
they may try to quash a subpoena if
they're subpoenaed and if that's the
case they're going to have to show that
the subpoena is unreasonable and
oppressive so we'll see if they argue
against it yeah it's one of those times
i really really wish we had cameras in
federal courts because imagine being
able to see defense secretary get
cross-examined about a theron oh ceo
case that would be huge but of course we
can't do that in federal courts thank
you both we turn now to an update from
the so-called doomsday duo now stalling
in the trials of chad daybell and his
wife lori valodebel
both are charged with the murders of
laurie's two children j.j valo and tyler
ryan both kids disappeared in september
2019 and their bodies were discovered
buried in chad dabel's backyard in june
of the following year in a ruling made
wednesday a judge determined lori valo
is still not competent to participate in
her own court proceedings this comes
after she was committed to the idaho
department of health and welfare back in
june when a mental health professional
determined she wasn't fit for trial on
wednesday judge stephen boyce ruled her
hospital stay would continue for another
180 days meantime chad dabel's trial
date will be pushed back again after a
motion was filed to change the trial's
venue and deba waived the right to a
speedy trial really it would be
impractical to try to commence this case
two months from today on november 8th i
understand there may also be some
discovery issues that are not yet
completed so
the court really on its own motion feels
like it's probably appropriate to
continue this trial
and so that's
where i think we're headed
the change of venue hearing is set for
early next month prosecutors say they
plan to seek the death penalty for chad
daybel if he's convicted
new information into our newsroom as
nixium co-founder and president nancy
salzman is sentenced to three and a half
years behind bars for racketeering
conspiracy you may remember salzman from
her work with cult leader keith raniere
in the nexium organization made famous
in the hbo documentary the vow rene ann
salzman purported nexium as a self-help
organization but really use it as a
front to coerce women to have sex with
renire create a secret society and even
brand themselves rene and salzman were
arrested in 2018 and salzman pled guilty
to her charges the following year in
october 2020 renier was sentenced to
life in prison
a florida man is charged with
first-degree murder in the death of a
23-year-old mother he tells authorities
was having an intimate relationship with
all while dating her mother at the same
time
it's a twisted web of relationships for
45 year old eric westergard who was
charged with first-degree murder on
monday this comes after 23 year old
parent damron's body was found in the
okeechobee waterway canal on sunday
westergard told officials he was dating
damron's mother but having an affair
with the victim at the same time
westergard told police he had been
smoking marijuana with damron on
saturday when she failed to cut her head
he then gathered garbage bags tape rope
and a cinder block to weigh her body
down in a nearby canal westergard is
being held in jail without bond
still ahead on law and crime daily
closing arguments continue in the trial
of california versus robert durst we'll
hear from the prosecution who doubled
down on durst's motivation to kill susan
berman but first latrell of r kelly is
back in session as more accusers take
the stand their shocking claims of
sexual assault some saying they were
locked inside the singer studio for days
on end
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back after three days off the r
kelly trial was back in session with two
more uncharged accusers testifying
against the disgraced king of r b
one woman identified only as sonja told
the jury she interviewed r kelly in 2003
when she was a 21 year old intern at a
salt lake city radio station sonya
testified that when she arrived she
waited in a room for three to four days
without food or water and when she
finally got something to eat she became
extremely full and tired when she awoke
she saw kelly doing up his pants and her
underwear resting on an armchair as
sonja left one of our kelley's
associates made her sign an nda and told
her not to tell anyone what happened and
that she did not want to mess with r
kelly her testimony was the first time
she spoke about what happened publicly
something the defense grilled her about
another accuser anna also testified
saying that she first met r kelly
backstage at a south carolina concert
when she was 19 years old they exchanged
numbers at a meet and greet with her
mother there months later she saw kelly
at his atlanta home the relationship
soon became sexual and before it ended
in december 2018 she would travel to
concerts to see him to north carolina
new york arizona and california and also
confirmed that there were strict rules
for kelly's girlfriends no makeup wear
baggy clothes and needing permission to
go out and if they broke them there were
harsh punishments next prosecutors
brought up previous text messages that
anna says she was forced to send by r
kelly saying that she was recorded being
spanked and told to send a text that she
liked it when she did not
let's bring back legal analyst dina dahl
and co-host terry austin to break down
this testimony terry how does it work
when you have uncharged accusers and
charged accusers what is the jury
supposed to do with their testimony
you know what brian i don't think that
they are as concerned about whether or
not this particular individual is
charging i think they're going to look
at each of these witnesses and determine
how credible they are the sonja witness
who testified that she was in a room
locked up for three days that seems
incredible but it depends on how the
jury perceived her testimony she said
she ate this chinese food that she felt
tired that she felt
groggy and you know the point is is she
saying she was drugged it all really
depends on how she comes across and
whether or not they believe her and i
think the fact that this happened in
2003 this is the first time she's
testifying they may just hold that
against her yeah possibly dean a
reasonable doubt for the defense can
often be swayed by the number of victims
could this be one too many accusers for
the defense to argue these accusers are
all wrong or exaggerating
absolutely you know it changes the
dynamic from a he said she said to he
said they said the more people who have
the similar story and they do the
controlling nature the punishment the
forcing to send messages
that the more likely the jury will find
the credible the witnesses who are being
charged
he is being charged with that crime
credible and that's very important and
it really may be one too many yeah this
really is he said she said she said she
said she said she said as continues with
more and more testimony thank you both
we turn now to ohio where stanley ford
is accused of setting three fires in his
akron neighborhood
stanley ford is accused of killing nine
people in two deadly house fires he's
also accused of sending fire to a parked
car where no one was harmed if convicted
stanley ford could face the death
penalty on the stand is retired
detective tanisha stewart who was the
lead detective on the case back in 2017.
detective stewart was stood a tough
cross-examination where the defense
attorney joe gorman revealed some holes
in her investigation that revealed a
suspect's alibi wasn't thoroughly
investigated
did you ever speak to gloria lee i did
not do you know if anybody spoke to
gloria lee i can't recall the top right
if they spoke to her or not but it was
not sufficient to mine
where is the action taken or were it in
your report of investigation does it say
the video
at that apartment complex was viewed by
somebody to determine whether he was
there or not
it's not written in my report
was it ever done
at this late date i can't say
absolutely someone did go and check that
out but at this late day i can't tell
you what their findings were
but whatever they were if they if i
didn't write in my report i solidified
this and it wasn't there to my liking
on redirect the state asked her what
brought her to the conclusion that
ford undoubtedly set those fires
however you have a commonality between
the two
and that's one person why in two
separate fires
are these two sets of people
running to mr ford's mother's house
getting access cutting on the same light
inside
using the same alarm codes to to
access and and
two sets of two totally sets of
different family members
what's the commonality the commonality
is mr ford thought that they were
horrible people
coming up on law and crime daily the
trial of robert durst continues as
closing arguments stretch into their
second day
ahead of jury deliberation we bring you
the specific jury instructions as the 12
jurors decide durst's fate
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
closing arguments are underway in robert
durst's trial before hearing them the
judge read instructions to the jury law
and crimes anget levy tells us what are
exactly are in those instructions
jury instructions can be tedious but
they're very important they're
essentially a road map for the jurors to
follow while they're deliberating
you must not let bias
sympathy
prejudice
or public opinion influence your
assessment of the evidence parts of the
jury instructions read by judge mark
windham and robert durst trial are
pretty standard the people are not
required to prove that the defendant had
a motive to commit the crime charged but
there are some things that are different
that the jury will have to consider when
weighing robert durst's fate
the defendant is guilty of first-degree
murder if the people have proved that
the defendant murdered while lying in
weight
meaning the jury has to find durst
concealed his purpose or had a secret
plan the instructions include special
circumstances to the murder including
that durst intended to kill susan berman
two
susan berman was a witness to a crime
three the killing was not committed
during the commission of the crime to
which susan berman was a witness and
four the defendant intended that susan
berman be killed to prevent her from
testifying in a criminal proceeding the
prosecution must also prove durst used a
firearm intentionally to find him guilty
of first degree murder and that it
caused berman's death
however evidence of the defendant fled
cannot prove guilt
by itself
closing arguments will last for several
days but just how long the jury
deliberates that's completely up to them
for law and crime daily i'm angelette
levy
thanks angeanette after the break we'll
bring you back into the courtroom for
dursa's closing arguments how the
prosecution's hammering down on durs's
motive and recounts his past track
record of lying on the record
[Music]
on to the west coast where closing
arguments are underway in the california
v robert durst trial
durst a real estate heir from new york
is on trial from the 2000 murder of his
best friend susan berman durst claims he
discovered berman's body in her benedict
canyon home panicked and left the scene
he later admitted to sending the
infamous cadaver note to help lead
officers to her body durst is accused of
murdering berman because she had
information about his wife kathy who
went missing in 1982. though a body has
never been found durst is also suspected
of her murder after four months of
lengthy testimony closing arguments
began on wednesday with the
prosecution's team splitting arguments
between them delivering their statements
to the jury prosecutors emphasized
durst's tendency to lie
he raised his hand and he took an oath
to tell the truth to all of you
that's a solemn oath
it's a solemn promise it's the
cornerstone of our system of justice
as jurors you rely on witnesses you rely
on evidence
not prejudice not conjecture not passion
you rely on evidence and you rely on
what these people tell you and that's
why they tell and take an oath would you
lie under oath to help your case
yes
we know otherwise now
what he thinks of that oath
he sat here he raised his hand he swore
to tell the truth and then he proceeded
to admit to you that he would lie under
oath
the state then delved into what they
believe were berman's real motives in
being durst's spokesperson and why they
made her a threat to the real estate air
so what did susan do as a spokesperson
was she acting
in a
endeavor
to help find
his missing wife to help him deal with
his grief
was this a coordinated attack
on kathy
so that the police would be distracted
and go in a different direction
it wasn't about right or wrong it was
just about loyalty that's who susan was
was it to find kathy was that her goal
and how she was actually acting
or was it to help her friend out of this
mess
susan posed a threat to him
to janine pirro who he feared was going
to indict him and he killed her
because she was a witness
to silence her
to stop her from ever taking that stand
from stop her from ever talking to the
police
another threat to robert durst was
kathy's best friend gilberta namaji who
the prosecution is claiming could have
been next on durham's hit list because
she kept pointing the finger at him
he knew gilberta was a threat
and so what does he do
he's got her address in his car during
this period of time when he knows she's
the threat and she's he's on the run he
has her phone number
he has
a map to the county where she lives
which would lead him
right to that address
he's got
not one
but two guns
two
along with that note
he's got 80 rounds of ammunition
he wants you to believe that was to
commit suicide
come on use your common sense
dean of the prosecution in california
gets to rebut the defense's closing
arguments and lewin will be doing it
what should we expect from that rebuttal
summation that we didn't see in this
first one
you know in his closing argument the
prosecutor says that robert's testimony
was similar to a cockroach soup because
of all the lies and you know robert
durst didn't manage to kind of take
control of his cross-examination in a
way that did muddy the waters the
defense attorney when he gets up is
going to try to muddy the waters even
more what the prosecution needs to do is
we have four months of testimony here
and the defendant's attorney may muddy
it pretty well he will need to simplify
and clarify that testimony and all the
evidence in a way for the jury to be
able to make this decision
in favor of what the prosecution wants
yeah interesting point terry let's
piggyback off of that are you seeing any
reasonable doubt from the defense that
the prosecution may not have answered in
their summation
brian i do not see any reasonable doubt
in this case at all i don't think the
jury is going to see any reasonable
doubt the prosecution has done a great
job lying out all of the evidence in
front of this jury the only thing i
think the defense can do is to dina's
point clarify their position and one of
the things they will probably try to say
is this is all circumstantial we don't
have any evidence and in fact durst was
not charged with kathy's disappearance
he wasn't convicted of murder as far as
morris black was concerned and so
there's no motive and so my client is
innocent i don't think it'll work
interesting argument we'll see how it
plays out thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you